[Music]
good morning and welcome to Wholesome
roots today I want to tell you a little
bit about how to start a food Forest on
the cheap the best way to do this is
rather than buying big PL fullsize trees
and shrubs and plants is to get seeds
and cuting from friends it's a very very
easy way to get items for free that you
can grow in your own garden I have a
bunch of paaw seeds that I'm going to be
starting today paaw seeds need to be
used fresh and stored in the
refrigerator through the
winter after you have harvested them so
when you harvest them out of the fruit
you remove all of the fruit off of the
seed put them into a Ziploc baggie with
some Pete Moss that's been dampened so
that they stay moist in your fridge so
that they get cold
stratification and are ready to be
planted in the spring
so I'm going to be planting some paaw
from fruit that I got from a friend I'm
going to be planting some other things
as well that friends have sent me so
basically what I did is I put a post on
Facebook I said does anybody have any
seeds or cuting of any fruit trees that
they would be willing to share with me
and I got a huge response and a bunch of
people have sent me some cuting and some
seeds and it didn't cost them anything
but postage because these things are
free so look around you when you're
driving down the road and you see an Old
Homestead that has fruit trees ask them
about getting cuting that nine times out
of 10 they don't even harvest the fruit
off of that tree anyway and they'd be
glad to let you trim a few branches off
these are just some of the cuting that
I've been able to receive when I
requested if anybody had any fruit
cuting I could get and here we are
starting our own fruit Orchard we're
preparing the area for our food Forest
right here in our vegetable garden we
decided the best location for our food
was to be as close to everything else
that we work with every day one of the
main principles of permaculture is using
what you have and keeping things simple
and easy and keeping your zones in the
correct order so having our Orchard way
back on the other side of our property
way on the other side where nobody ever
goes was not the best idea when we
originally planted it so we'll be moving
whatever fruit trees have survived the
deer damage up into this location with
all of our understory fruit trees
planted underneath them so we're doing
layers we're going to have some tall
trees some shrubs and bushes some Vines
and some gr ground
cover so that we have a perfect
permaculture Community growing in our
garden now these won't just be fruit
trees and bushes we're also going to
have comrey and artichoke and all kinds
of interesting in things growing in that
Community to help keep it healthy and
strong and
thriving it's important to keep in mind
that every type of fruit has a different
set of
circumstances that it likes to grow by
whether it's from a cutting or seed so
make sure you research each one of those
fruits that you're planning on starting
from seed or cuting to make sure that
you're taking care of them properly for
instance the pawpaw has to be kept wet
and cold for a cold stratification there
are some seeds that are going to need to
be soaked beforehand there are some
seeds that are going to need to be
nicked and have their seed coat
Disturbed before you plant them some
cuting are easy to take and will do very
well for you others have to be grafted
onto a root stock so do a little bit of
research about the plants that you're
looking at starting before you begin to
make sure that you get even more success
in your garden I also got some free Paw
Paw seeds from Kentucky State University
anybody can get free seeds from the
University as they have them available
so I will leave a link down below for
more information on that so you can get
your free paaw seeds to start your own
paaw Grove all right so I
have almost completely filled my tray
this is a deep root always want to do
deep root pots especially for paaw
because they have a tap route I have
then poked holes with my fingers to make
make it deeper paaw seeds like to be
planted at least 3 in deep so I've
soaked them in some water just to get
them started this morning and I'm just
going to go ahead and put a seed in each
one of these
cells and hope that they're all going to
workow
[Music]
I'm actually going to go ahead and
double the seeds because I don't need
this many paw paws and um some of them
kind of have some spots on them that I'm
curious if they may be a little bit
damaged so I'm going to go ahead
and double seed what I have left in this
bag so that I'll have a fresh tray to
plant my Kentucky seeds
in any extra paaw plants that I will not
be planting here I can share with fellow
gardeners in my area and make sure that
you always remember that if you start a
little bit extra you can help spread the
gardening movement with other gardeners
by sharing your extra plants that's
something I really stress and try to do
as much as possible I've had so many
people share their plants with me and I
try to pay it forward by sharing plants
with other gardeners in my area some of
these could possibly even be shipped if
I am really
[Applause]
careful so that almost doubled the
entire seed
tray actually I think it's going to just
about only going to be shy a few cells
so that's going to
be good to go I'm going to cover fill
the cells the rest of the way up water
it in and I'm going to put it
outside it is good for paaw seeds to be
in the cold and they will germinate as
the temperatures warm up and they can
take a while to germinate so I'll just
have to be patient
[Music]
[Applause]
just got to get some rain water with
collected to water them in and we're
good to go I'm just going to leave them
and let the mother nature take care of
them from here
[Music]
all right so I've got my warm
temperature things that I am planting in
this tray so I've got some goji berry
from a friend some meringer from a seed
Swap and some hearty orange that I got
from Baker Creek and I just opened it up
and look they're already sprouting so
I'm going to have to be very careful
with those so I don't break off any of
those little tiny
babies so here we are with all of our
seeds
sewn watered in all of our cuting
growing this is how you start a food
Forest I have a big huge thank you to
the friends that have sent us seeds and
cuting and allowed us to get this
started and I will be sharing seeds and
cuting in the future with more and more
people I hope that this is inspired you
to start your own food Forest using free
things that you can get from Friends
neighbors I mean really anywhere you
could even post on Facebook in some of
the marketplaces and there's lots of
people who are willing to give away
these things for free so don't stop
looking and don't stop growing keep up
the good work and we'll see you next
time on wholesome roots
[Music]